ultimately when bad boys will be cooking
on the inside to sell on the outside
it's not going to be easy and first I
gotta convince the prison governor ed
Tala and his team about my plan for a
working business kitchen morning you
ready
this is the beginning of an ongoing
project the objective is to stand alone
kitchen that can be a proper business
within the prison kitchens can function
from a thousand pound a week to you know
50,000 pound a week and turnover the
dream would be for it to make money
generate income and put back in come and
go over the years and what we're really
interested in is something which is
sustained the ones that are last that's
the bit going forward that slightly
worries me because kind of getting a
business out of this keeping the kitchen
going working it around our regime it's
gonna be a massive task for bricks
dinner I know it's a big ask and yeah
my balls are on the line being in a
prison is not the same as being working
on the outside offenders you know you
can't underestimate that they are not
always an easy bunch to work with
they're not used to working on a
nine-to-five basis they're not
necessarily used to to come to work I
mean told what to do and then taking it
the right way it is a very new thing for
them and they had to get used to it the
six-month time I want to leave this
prison with a pop of working commercial
kitchen so right now I've got 22
incompetent prisoners and that's just
way too much for me to handle
I'm gonna scale it down get a dynamic 12
my bad-boy brigade
none of this lot can cook but are they
any good at anything I've devised the
test to see if any of them can learn to
cook or sell what we cook to make money
if they can't do either they're out
morning how are we we're gonna make some
fairy cakes we love them you like fairy
cakes what's the secret good fairy cakes
barking - now I want to see your
imagination go wild I want you to
decorate it with something finesse show
me what you can do on the top of a
cupcake yeah now this thing here the
kitchen kitty don't you look at that box
and take it serious are we gonna sell
those cupcakes we were split into two
teams half you will bake and half of you
will try to convince our prison officers
to buy your cupcakes I'll be a setup
you'll be a seller can get your hands
out your pockets don't blame yourself I
need I need a piece of city
okay all the baking team have to do is
follow my simple fairy cake recipe you
got glasses on the night a pinch of salt
waters a pinch mean they're all
committing GBH against kegs round here
guys guys guys guys look at me all of
you stop we've all put the [ __ ]
butter into the flour
[ __ ] you no [ __ ] cupcake would
[ __ ] throw that away
really a little cool for cupcakes where
I come from the line